Jonathan and Washington's gonna start us
off hi Jonathan how are you hi Dave
thanks love take my call I'm doing
pretty good good how can I help today
well I had a question for you just so
you know I just discovered you a couple
months ago and I made my mistakes with
credit cards and buying too much collar
and and all that good stuff and took a
second job we're chipping away at paying
off our debt there the bar cards how
much should be paid off seeing it slowly
working away at it we're still getting
getting rolled through the baby steps I
got my first emergency fund in place and
just making extra payments on things so
yeah it's still still getting started a
couple thousand I guess okay but the
biggest thing is it's hard for me to
keep my mouth shut when I'm talking to
people a lot to all my friends and
family like a you know don't don't be
going into debt don't be borrowing money
for anything and the same thing I keep
hearing is oh well I have a credit card
for emergencies and it's great because I
get points and then I just pay it off
every month how am I supposed to
convince people that that's still a bad
idea to even have one that they think
they're getting some deal with points or
miles well to start with you're just
getting started so you don't really need
to convince anybody yeah you just need
to do your thing right that's like
that's like a full-time job right there
so you know but but in in basically the
concept is this if you get 1% back on
your Discover card that means that if
you have a thousand dollars from
discover you spent a hundred thousand
dollars to cause that to happen
yeah on what planet is that smart yeah
that we go through a hundred grand to
come up with one mmm-hmm that's
absolutely asinine and yet people walk
around like they did something smart
there's nothing smart about that yeah I
get airline miles well great
you think those are free UNIX antics
lives at the airline and the credit card
company where do you think those airline
miles come from doofus you're paying for
them that's where they come from
you know yeah and so you know it to
start with you can hardly use the
airline miles Consumer Reports says 78%
of airline miles never go there are
never redeemed and so if they're never
redeemed you know what they're worth
zero and so your rationalization 78% of
the time is stupid the correctional
assertions are always stupid but that
just firms it up right and so and you
know the last thing is this if you want
to be a millionaire you should ask
millionaires what they do with money not
broke people and millionaires I've met
with tens of thousands of them in 30
years I have never met a millionaire
they said Dave you know my financial
breakthrough was those airline miles
yeah make sense they never say that as a
matter of fact they never used credit
cards a few of them have credit cards
the vast majority don't that's what our
study shows and even the ones that have
them not one of them says oh I do it for
the airline miles that's always broke
people that say stuff like that yeah
rich people don't say stuff like that
broke people ask how much down how much
a month rich people ask how much yeah no
people have their way yeah I broke
people a big-screen library a big-screen
TV Zig Ziglar used to say rich people
have libraries mm-hmm and you know just
start thinking about in other words what
is the value system the character
qualities the habit patterns and the
uses of money that people that have
wealth and have kept it use and you want
to emulate those who's not what broke
people do so if you know you're just
getting started and it broke people make
fun of your financial plan it means
you're right on track my friend okay
yeah I mean I'm not having second my
cards but you know I did the same thing
I'll use it for groceries and all this
stuff and paid off every month and then
it gets out of control
always does and you spend more by the
way when you spend with plastic yeah
because it doesn't act paint cash when
you use it activates the paint centers
of the brain plastic does not and so you
just don't have an emotional connection
when you're going to cruise you go to
Disney World they let your room key be
your charge card all week and that's so
they can sell you an $8 ice cream cone
yeah
and you don't even think about it you're
just like we've the room key you know
because it does not activate the pain
centers of the brain it's low friction
emotionally and you buy more stuff when
you use a credit card instead of cash
you spend 12 to 18 percent more on the
average purchase on a smaller purchase a
lot more vending machines a hundred and
seventy eight percent increase when they
put in credit cards over cash a hundred
and seventy eight percent increase would
you like to increase your business
owners of the eight percent most of us
would now larger the item the smaller
the increase right but the average
purchase is twelve to eighteen percent
fast food purchase is right around 40
percent increase when they with a card
using purchaser instead of a cash
purchaser when you spend cash at Mickey
D's you go give me the give me the kids
meal right when you spend cash it when
you spend your credit card you're like
yeah I'll take one of those at the apple
pie and I buy the guy behind me is you
know I mean you just overspend your butt
off because you don't emotionally
register the expenditure and I teach
this for a living and have for 30 years
and I personally experienced this I
personally don't realize I'm spending
money when I'm using even a debit card
because my debit cards got plenty of
money in the account so I can kind of do
with it whatever I want right and so
even in that case I mean when I'm on a
cruise or I'm on a property where you
can just use the card you charge stuff
to the room it's the same thing it's low
friction emotionally you don't think
anything about it and I did a purchase
that should have been fifteen dollars
when I was on that Australia trip and
when I got the bill at the end it was an
item that I pay fifteen dollars for and
when I got to the end of the stay at
that location is my fault I didn't ask I
didn't look
completely my fault I got the bills a
hundred and fifteen dollars about had a
coronary just because I was so stupid
I wouldn't have bought that anymore than
fly the moon but I just like oh yeah
give me one of those and you know we're
dinner give me one of those and yeah
give me two of those and you know you
just there's no emotional friction when
there's not real money on the table you
don't register it and that's you know
that's the lesson that we've been
teaching for a long time Jonathan and so
a really really good question and you
know all of us that do marketing we know
that the more times you the more things
you have to do in order to buy our
product a website that requires you to
go through five hoops
that's called friction in the website
world if you have to go through five
hoops to buy something it gets too hard
you abandon the cart and walk away
conversion rate goes down and so that's
why Amazon Prime is just making a
freaking killing you can just push that
little button and you buy stuff and it
shows up on your porch you do not
emotionally register the expenditure
just boom boom boom boom and they get
those easy buttons one of our friends
toddler hit the easy button six times I
got all these toilet paper on the front
porch